the pandemic has shown that the global
community can come together to tackle a
crisis now the archbishop of canterbury
is calling for the same for climate
change uh joining us now is the
archbishop of canterbury justin welby
archbishop lovely to have you on the
program i do hope you are well um
and we will talk about your your call
for united concerted action in just a
second but i wonder if we might start
with your own personal commitment to
putting your house in order in terms of
environmental issues i am reliably
informed that you are you are eating
less meat and that even your diesel car
or the archbishop wheel as i'm going to
christen it this morning is on its way
out
uh it's long gone yes i haven't used it
for a year
and uh where uh
once we can we don't have enough we've
cut back so we just have our own car we
have no official car or anything like
that
and uh yes we're eating a bit less me
we're trying to be disciplined like
everyone else it's step by step um and
we're trying to be disciplined about how
we behave
and uh to recycle and all that
um and get out of the habits that i get
into and now get ticked off about uh by
the family of you know automatically
putting food in the bin rather than
recycling it and you you name it it's
just the small things but every day it
gets a bit better
and indeed but of course it's not
through individual action that we are
going to be able to deal with the
problems affecting the planet is through
global concerted action hence your
message
well yes the message uh you very kindly
said that i'd issued the message it's
actually rather more than that um i went
along with a message uh i we've had a
joint message issued by myself by the
pope and by the ecumenical patriarch the
head of the orthodox church
uh based in istanbul and by the pope in
rome and we're meeting up together in
fact in a few weeks
to begin the cop 26 engagement of
religious
uh of these three faiths of these three
uh churches engaging with cop 26.
um and uh
it's never happened before that the
three of us have issued a joint
statement like that it's never happened
in history that the three of issued a
joint statement and that's to say that
this is urgent
it's really important and it's for
individuals for companies and
institutions and for governments
it can't be left to government or left
to companies or left to individuals
what what though can can faith leaders
like the three of you do in terms of
compelling you know uh politicians who
at times have seem pretty tone deaf as
to the the risks and the the the
emergency that climate change has caused
what levers can you pull on what a side
obviously from the millions of people
who follow your respective religions
well uh the three churches have between
them
uh the thick end of one and
three-quarter billion peoples that's
yeah that's a lot of people
um the
what we can do as faith leaders is first
encourage
uh the idea of changing
uh our attitude to the climate of
reconciliation with the creation with
which unconsciously we've been at war
for so long and done so much damage to
peace building with our creation that's
something that the world wants
it is not something that the vast
majority of people are hostile to they
need leadership cop 26
offers them the opportunity
to um
show that leadership but it's they're
not going against the stream they're
going with the stream so we can
encourage
secondly
we can take action ourselves church of
england take a small example
uh all its parishes and schools and so
on all its property we're going zero
carbon by 2030. thirdly we can use um
voices and voting power
through investments uh you'll have seen
in the press this morning the transition
pathway initiative started by the church
of england chaired by the church of
england with over 10 trillion dollars
of investment from investment companies
of all sorts around the world
has set out
a way of measuring
whether
oil and gas companies and extractive
industries are actually performing as
they promise
in going to zero carbon and we will
disinvest
by 2023 for those who aren't meeting the
uh standard and not heading in the right
direction so there's a ton of things
that's only a very small example there's
a ton of things we can do
i'm glad to hear you said it's good to
see someone well you'd expect the
archbishop of canterbury uh to be filled
with a little bit more hope than a
cynical journalist like myself but it is
positive it's good to hear such
positivity at this time of the day
archbishop great to have you on the
program this morning thanks for being
with us